SPEAKER 1: And
I'm really honored
to be hosting Shabnam
Tolouei here today
to discuss the
impact of immigration
on professional career.
Shabnam is an award winning
Iranian actress, theater
director, and playwright.
She's won multiple awards from
the International Fajre Theater
Festival, which is the most
prestigious venue for theater
in Iran.
In 2006, however, her
successful career came to a halt
when the Iranian
government banned her
from working due
to her religion.
Determined to resist efforts to
stifle her artistic expression,
she relocated to France
to restart her career.
She is most widely
known internationally
for her starring role
as Munis in the award
winning Iranian film,
"Women Without Men."
In 2016, she costarred in
[INAUDIBLE] in the Stanford
Festival of Iranian
Arts, and co-directed--
and directed the documentary
"Dust, Flower, Flame."
Thank you so much for taking
the time to be here, Shabnam.
SHABNAM TOLOUEI: Thank you
so much for the invitation.
SPEAKER 1: My first question
is around your experience
being a female actress
in Iran, and how
that changed once
you moved to France,
which is relative liberal
and secular country?
SHABNAM TOLOUEI: First of
all, my second language
is not English.
It's French, so I see
many Iranian faces here.
So if I'm in difficulty and
I'm searching for a word,
I will ask everyone to help me.
SPEAKER 1: Fair.
SHABNAM TOLOUEI: So I apologize,
because I am just using
English word to express myself.
When you're an actress in
Iran, you just have a face.
You don't have any body.
Because your body
seems to provoke men,
according to government.
Whatever.
So all the expressions in front
of camera comes from this part.
You're sad, you're happy.
Whatever, it happens here.
Not in your body.
Your body is covered.
You don't have the right
to run in front of camera.
We don't have the
right, as audience,
to see your body, your--
how can you say?
How do you say?
Bumps?
You don't have the
right to show that.
You are playing the
role of a mother.
You are seeing your
son after 25 years.
This is a scenario.
When you see your
son, you faint.
You can't go toward
him and hug him.
Because you can't
touch your son,
the person who is playing
the role of your son.
You are playing
the role of a wife.
It's night.
You want to go to bedroom.
But you don't go to bedroom.
You lie on sofa in the hall
and your husband go to bedroom.
You lie down with a scarf.
We see you sleeping with
a scarf, just this part.
So there are many difficulties
for women, for actresses.
But when you're living in
Iran, you are used to see that.
So you imagine-- we have
a very strong imagination
as an audience.
So the woman faints.
And you know that, oh OK.
She's hugging her son.
The woman is lying on the sofa.
You imagine, oh, OK.
She is making love
with her husband.
OK.
I see that.
In theater, it's a
little different.
Because the audience
is less than
the audience of TV
series or cinema.
So you feel kind of
freedom as a playwright
or as a theater director.
So you can see the
body still covered.
But the body movement.
There is an important
body language when you're
an actress in theater in Iran.
And there are many red lines.
There are many prohibitions
that you cannot cross easily
in Iran.
Intellectual matters-- this is
not just sexual or whatever.
We have many examples
in Iran of filmmakers
who are banned to work,
or even they are arrested.
They are in prison
now because they
wanted to cross the red lines.
When you leave your
country, and when
you go to a secular country--
first of all, I think this
is not what happened for me.
But I see many actresses go--
I mean, they accept many
actresses in free countries
except to have naked photos.
Because they are frustrated.
And they want to-- this is some
kind of-- it's some kind of--
how can I say?
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
SPEAKER 2: Rebellion.
SHABNAM TOLOUEI: Rebel-- yes.
They are-- [INAUDIBLE]?
SPEAKER 2: Rebellion.
SHABNAM TOLOUEI: Rebellion.
OK.
This is kind of rebellion act.
They want to say that I exist,
and I want to show my body,
and I want to be against
those laws, those tradition
or whatever.
But, for me, the most important
thing was intellectual freedom.
So, I tried to go
to the subjects
that I couldn't talk
about when I was in Iran.
Like two plays that
I had in Paris.
The play that recently,
weeks ago, a week ago,
I had in Stanford University,
called "Autumn Dance"
that we were seeing the trailer.
Or the film, the
documentary film
that I made about [INAUDIBLE],,
the first woman in Iran
in 170 years ago, the first
woman who unveiled herself.
The poetess.
And then she was killed.
So this is, I mean, this is--
this is the last part
of your question.
That it helped me a lot
to express myself easily
and to cross these
taboos and red lines.
When I write.
To France.
SPEAKER 1: Yeah.
I mean, I can imagine.
But, essentially having the
intellectual freedom now
to express yourself
was really important.
And so then, what was the most
difficult part of immigration,
both as an individual,
but also as a celebrity?
SHABNAM TOLOUEI: I think when
you leave your country when
you're a kid, it's--
I mean, it could be easier
than when you are adult,
because even if you are
attached to your friends
or to your neighbors or--
you are in the
beginning of your path.
You have a long way to go.
You are not already someone.
You want to become someone.
But when you have already
a career behind you,
when you are already
someone in your country
and you're forced to leave your
country, which was my case,
the most difficult
part is carrying
on your baggage, the baggage
that you have picked up
throughout the years, you
know, with your souvenirs,
with your love and hate
stories, with your--
with the scent of the
streets, the geography,
the history of your country.
When you arrive to
the new country,
it prevents you to go forward.
Because all the time
you open this baggage,
and you are comparing
everything with your past.
So, sometimes it even prevents
you to wake up in the morning.
You don't have
enough motivation.
This was my experience,
my own experience.
And according to what my friends
say, in the same situation,
I see that this is
a common problem.
So I needed a long time to
get rid of that to go forward.
SPEAKER 1: And I mean,
I think you're right.
I think a lot of the
challenges you faced
are just the feelings
is what's shared today
with immigrants and refugees.
What do you think helped you
overcome sort of the feeling
that you just described of
not being able to get up
or, you know, what provided
you with the resilience
to overcome over
the couple of years
that you've been in France now?
SHABNAM TOLOUEI: I
think as a human being,
I have the right to be
sad, to be depressed,
to be disappointed.
I had been.
I had serious episode
of deep depression
when I arrived in France.
But I think, in the
same time, I don't
have the right to stay in
this state of feeling or mind
or whatever.
So, I try to understand that
it's not important who I was.
It's important to see what
I can do in the moment,
in this country.
How can I restart everything?
It was a very long
process for me.
But maybe this helped me
to overcome everything.
SPEAKER 1: No, I mean, I think
it's incredibly difficult,
and ultimately, you know,
as someone who, as you said,
had a career in
Iran, and you know,
your artistic expression
was rooted there.
And sort of the Iranian audience
defining what plays and acting
and all the things that
you participated in or led,
how do you think now,
having left Iran,
the Iranian audience
being far away,
how has that defined
your artistic expression?
You know, or what
are you leave today?
SHABNAM TOLOUEI: I think
the connection is not lost.
Because of the social media.
There are many, for all of--
I don't like the word celebrity.
For celebrities, for actresses,
for actors, for artists.
We can be in connection
with our fans.
But by fans, I
mean, the audience
who loves you, who love you, and
who send you positive energy.
And who expect you
to produce something.
So this is a very
great motivation.
On the other hand,
you are not updated,
because you are far
from your country.
But, there is another positive
point when you are far.
Because you have a
wider perspective.
So you can look at
everything in another way.
Even now, I know, even if I
want to talk about someone
in a village in Iran, I can
talk about this person in a way
to be understandable
for a wider audience.
Even for European audience.
Even for American audience.
Because now I see that there
are many common aspects
between all human beings.
This is not being Iranian.
When I want to talk
about Iranian people,
there is no need to be Iranian
to have Iranian audience.
Another point is that, when
you are outside your country,
nobody knows you.
Even your-- [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
compatriots?
SPEAKER 1: Yeah.
Compatriots.
SHABNAM TOLOUEI: Even
your compatriots.
So, even if they know you, they
don't-- they have their own
struggles.
They have their
own daily problems.
So you need to create
some kind of demand
in the audience to tell
them that, hey, I exist.
I am here.
And I have something
to share with you.
So please come and read my text.
Please come and watch my play.
Please, please come
and let's cry together.
Let's laugh together.
So all the time the artists
who are outside Iran--
I know many of my friends as
well, they do the same as me.
We are doing [INAUDIBLE].
How can I say?
Self promotions.
All the time.
And this helps.
I mean, this helps you
to become demanded,
wanted in a positive way.
So, these are the solutions that
you find to keep the connection
and to create a new
audience outside your--
SPEAKER 1: And would you say
that, in sort of widening
the audience, as
you said, maybe it's
not just Iranians,
but Europeans,
is important for Iranian art?
SHABNAM TOLOUEI:
I think so, yes.
It's very important,
because, unfortunately, there
is kind of stereotype about
Middle Eastern countries
and people.
So, when you talk
about your country,
and when you show
what is happening,
not about politicians
or whatever,
but you talk about real people,
they see that you are equal.
We are human beings.
We are-- and I am
not representative
of Iranian regime.
But I am exactly the same as
Chinese actress or whatever.
You know?
So, yes, I think it's
very important to break
these stereotype image.
SPEAKER 1: Absolutely.
And overall, what has
been important to you
as an immigrant woman?
You know?
SHABNAM TOLOUEI: I don't think
that there was anything special
of being immigrant woman.
I'm not sure if I were a man--
you know, I studied
for this phrase.
If I were-- because I thought
that I should say, if I was.
And then I learned if I were.
If I were a man, I'm not sure
if it could change anything.
If more doors could be opened
for me or less doors, you know,
could be open for me.
I think the notion of
exile is so difficult.
When you choose to go to another
country, you are an immigrant.
When you you're forced
to leave your country,
which was my case, as many other
Iranians after the revolution.
So, even if you are not exiled,
but this notion of exile
is inside you.
So it's so hard.
It [INAUDIBLE].
It's so heavy.
And it doesn't change--
your gender doesn't
change anything, I think.
SPEAKER 1: Yeah.
No.
I think these feelings are
probably transcending a lot of,
you know, whether it's gender
or occupation, in the sense
that it's so deep and hard
to come to terms with.
So, how does one
come to terms with--
I guess, one of
my final questions
is, how do you stay resilient?
And what would-- if you
have any insights or advice
or something that you can share,
just how do you stay positive?
SHABNAM TOLOUEI: Huh.
This is a very--
how to stay positive.
I think this is a question
from the beginning of time.
SPEAKER 1: True.
SHABNAM TOLOUEI:
You know, let me say
why I was forced to leave Iran.
Because after that,
I can answer, maybe,
better your question.
The artists, and
especially the artists
in the field of cinema
and theater in Iran
are the representative
of Islamic society.
So if you are not Muslim,
you will be in trouble.
I'm not Muslim.
I'm Baha'i.
As a Baha'i-- you can
Google what is Baha'i.
I don't want to talk about
Baha'i beliefs or whatever.
But as Baha'i, when
you are Baha'i,
you say that I am Baha'i
when you are asked.
You don't deny your beliefs.
When you deny your
beliefs, it means that you
are not-- you are not Baha'i.
[INAUDIBLE]
Finished.
So I was playing in
a famous TV series.
And then, there's a
famous questionnaire
that must be filled by
all the artists in Iran.
Especially the artists who
work with the national TV.
The first question is your name.
The second one is
your family name.
The third one is
your father's name.
No mother's name is needed.
Just father's name.
And then the fourth
question is your religion.
I wrote Baha'i.
And then, the person
who was the agent
of security service, the
intelligence service,
he took back the questionnaire.
He looked at it.
His eyes were shining.
You know?
I was the fish in the trap.
He was so happy about that.
And since he knew that, OK,
this is the last day of my work,
he asked me to take a selfie
with him for his family.
So we did that.
And then, I was called
by the intelligence
service or whatever.
So they were very angry.
And they were saying, oh,
where were you all these years?
And why didn't we know
that you are Baha'i?
And now you need to convert
to Islam, because you will
be the example of whatever.
And I was saying,
no, please, please.
Let me work, let me work.
Because I'm not teaching
anything about Baha'i faith or
I'm not, whatever.
And I just want to work.
But, I'm Baha'i.
Anyway, they didn't accept it.
And it took two years.
It was very hard.
I was called every
time to the security--
I mean, we call it
security service,
and it is the intelligence
service in Iran.
So, this was my choice.
I could have chosen
another thing.
to write, I'm Muslim.
And I could have stayed in
Iran and continue my career.
I did something which, according
to many of my friends, even
my child, who is eight
years old, is not wise.
But I did that.
And then, I had to
accept the consequences.
It was very, very hard.
I could not even imagine that it
could be this much hard for me.
It was very hard.
This is why when I arrived
in Paris, I was lost.
I didn't know who I am,
where I am, why I am there.
And I had a serious depression.
But, since I believe
strongly, even now,
in personal responsibility.
So, I try to overcome
my depression and all
these mental and psychological
and social difficulties.
I said, OK.
I chose something.
This is my--
I mean, at that time, that
was the best choice, according
to my beliefs, according
to my personal identity,
according to my self-esteem,
to my personal image.
So now, I accept it.
And now, I should go forward.
And then, one day I
woke up, and I said, OK.
Now, rebirth.
There is another Shabnam.
That one doesn't exist anymore.
There are lots of beautiful
souvenirs from her.
We can Google her and
what she has done in Iran.
But that's finished.
Now, what do you want
to do here, in Paris?
How do you want to connect to
this society, to these people,
to understand why this
street has this name?
What is behind this?
What is behind these smiles?
What is behind this behavior
in the subways or whatever?
To understand the people
who are surrounding you.
And I think this is, for
me, I mean, in one word,
to be brief, to take
the responsibility.
And then to stay in
the present moment
was two keys that helped me to
open the door of my new life.
SPEAKER 1: And, you know, I
love this word that you used,
rebirth.
And it sounds like there was a
transformation of your identity
almost at this point.
What do you think, are today how
you define your identity today?
And how it's different?
How is it different
from the Shabnam
before that we can Google?
SHABNAM TOLOUEI: You still
can Google just career.
And we don't talk
about my identity.
When you are in a
country like Iran,
with a dominant
tradition, a regime that
tries to decide for you--
[INAUDIBLE]
SPEAKER 1: Patriarchy?
Patriarchy.
SHABNAM TOLOUEI: Yes.
What, these friends said.
Yes.
The power of father,
the power of men.
Even women don't--
I mean, even, yes.
In their psychology,
they have this,
I mean, this notion
that men have the right,
even if they object.
But inside their minds,
they think this way.
So the elements that you choose
to construct your identity
is somehow forced by tradition,
by family, by regime,
by propaganda.
Even by suppression.
You resist for something
that you're not sure
if you have the choice.
Will you choose the same?
The same way, even to
resist, or whatever?
When you are forced--
I mean, I emphasize the word
"forced" to leave the country--
and you land in a new country.
Suddenly you wake up.
And you say, who I am?
What is my real identity?
And you question all the
beliefs and the elements
that has built your self-image.
Your social identity.
Even your sexual identity.
I talk to many Iranians, and
they had the same experience.
They said, yes when we
were-- as an adult, I say.
When we arrive to,
for example, France,
we started questioning
ourselves if whether I'm
a homosexual or not.
Because you are not
sure if, you know--
you are free now to
be whatever you are,
or to choose whatever
you want to be.
But in Iran, it's not the same.
Even there isn't any
regime that suppress you.
This is a family.
You're scared to be
yourself, you know?
So, I had all these
questions about my identity.
And then, religious identity.
Why have I chosen to be Baha'i?
Were I influenced by my father?
Because I was born
in a mixed family.
Part of my family are Muslims.
Part are-- my paternal--
is it paternal?
Paternal part are Baha'is.
So I chose to be Baha'i.
But I'm not--
I mean, I started questioning
myself that, have I really--
have I really
chosen to be Baha'i?
Or was I influenced
by my father?
Or am I really the
person that I am now?
Have I really found my
place in the society?
Or didn't I have
any other option?
So this is why I became
an actress or whatever.
Am I not lesbian?
Because I had problems in
my love, in my love story.
So what is happening?
All these questions.
And then, I started to
rebuild my identity.
Finally, in a free country, I
understood that even if I am--
I have to-- I mean, I didn't
have any choice to be a woman.
But, I think this
is not important.
Gender, religion, or
nationality or whatever.
I'm a human being.
This is the most
important part, you
know, for me, of my identity.
This is what, you know, this
is a short time, a human being.
So you can't find any
movie [INAUDIBLE]..
But this is why I--
this is what-- this is the gift
of this immigration for me.
That I could get
rid of everything.
And then I choose
again what I want.
But I see that there is kind of
essence of a human being that
is most important thing.
I mean, more important
than all these elements.
So, was I clear?
SPEAKER 1: Yes.
SHABNAM TOLOUEI: OK, thank you.
SPEAKER 1: Yes, very much.
And my final question--
and it's a bit grand.
But what's the secret
to a happy life?
SHABNAM TOLOUEI: Oh my god.
SPEAKER 1: I said it was grand.
SHABNAM TOLOUEI: You know, this
is a philosophical question.
Again, since the
beginning of time.
There are many answers.
Many people say that no
expectation, whatever.
I was talking to
a friend a couple
of weeks ago about happiness.
And I'm just repeating
what I heard,
because I liked that so much.
Because I'm searching as well.
And, according to
this friend, when
you are in search of
happiness, you are lost.
Because happiness
is not outside.
Happiness is
something inside you.
So, if you are in
peace with yourself,
you're happy everyday.
For me, it was fantastic.
I'm not sure if I ever arrived
to this point, or how far am I.
But I hope some day,
I stop searching.
And I can open my heart and
see, oh, everything is here,
everything is here,
everything is here.
SPEAKER 3: So your
latest play at Stanford,
you were acting
as three persons.
And both were involved
in a situation
that they had to immigrate.
Someone was in prison.
Can you go over
that and you say--
you explain how it was
based off of your own story?
Or it was inspired by that.
SHABNAM TOLOUEI: Yes,
in "Autumn Dance,"
there are three women who
are experiencing exile,
even if they are in
their own country.
There is a journalist,
in Iran, in prison.
There is a prostitute
in Paris, who
pretends to be a
journalist, because she has
met this journalist in Iran.
So she wants to ask for--
asylum?
Asylum.
And there is another woman, the
sister of this real journalist,
who has left Iran
when she was 18.
She was imprisoned in Iran.
And now she is a dance teacher,
dance professor in Paris.
There was, in 2009, there
was a green movement in Iran.
Because of this false result
of elections when Ahmadinejad
was reelected in Iran.
There was a green movement,
and many, many journalists
were arrested in Iran.
Many young people who
were demonstrating outside
were killed.
So, I was inspired by this
green movement in Iran.
And the protests
of Iranian youth.
And I wrote this
play, based on what
I have heard about the
tortures in Iranian prisons
since the beginning
of the revolution.
And the personal experiences of
the women who were in prison,
who were raped in prisons,
who were touched in prisons,
sexually abused just to
confess to what they were not.
So, and then, in
2009, with this wave
of immigration,
many intellectuals,
again, left Iran.
And there were many
people who didn't really
have problems in Iran.
But they left Iran just to take
advantage of the situation.
And they tried to pretend
that they are someone else.
So all these matters
helped me, or made me,
to write "Autumn
Dance" and to play it.
SPEAKER 1: Great.
In your documentary,
"Dust, Flower, Flame,"
you described the
life of a 19th century
woman who impacted the Iranian
women's rights movement.
Do you feel like the Iranian--
the Iran's women's rights
movement is progressing
or regressing?
SHABNAM TOLOUEI: Progressing.
Of course.
I don't know the
exact percentage,
but I think it's more than
60% of Iranian students who
are women.
We have many physicians, many
engineers, many scientists
in Iran who are women.
In Iran, we forget that
we are wearing scarf.
We completely forget it.
You know?
And when we are outside Iran,
we say, oh, women in Iran are--
they have to put scarves.
And this is kind of obliga--
this is kind of obligation.
But it doesn't prevent
Iranian women to progress.
You know?
So, this is exactly the reason
that I chose this subject,
[INAUDIBLE].
Because I saw that Iranian women
are trying to cross the taboos,
to progress.
And to say what they want.
This was not the case
during the first years
after the revolution
because of war
and many, many other problems.
But when I read in internet--
I'm still reading-- what they
are doing, and how many women--
Muslim women-- who were against
the [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]..
Injust?
Injustice.
Injustice in Iran toward women.
They were arrested.
I thought that, OK.
This is the time to
talk about [INAUDIBLE]..
And to say that,
OK, 170 years ago,
something happened exactly.
And you won't need to
be executed like her.
So the path is
open now, I think.
SPEAKER 1: It's great.
Do we have a question?
SPEAKER 4: Oh, thank you
for your interesting talk.
As you already said,
many leave our country,
we leave everything behind.
And for example, for us,
our resume becomes empty.
And so, for example,
there is a feeling
that we want to prove
ourselves to the other people.
So, what did you do to
overcome this feeling?
SHABNAM TOLOUEI: I remember
when I was in Iran.
We were traveling most of
the time for our shows,
for our theater performances.
It was organized by
Iranian government.
And just the day
before our departure,
we were searching for
this handcraft Iranian,
you know, souvenirs, gifts,
to take with ourselves,
to show the European people that
we are the most generous people
in the world.
And then, we were talking
about our civilization.
It began in 2,500 years ago.
And we have that,
and we have this.
And then, [INAUDIBLE] appeared.
So, you know, [INAUDIBLE]
is an Iranian.
You know?
All the time, we were
trying to say that, I mean,
I am not the person
that you think.
I am not the stereotype.
You know?
But, when I lost
everything, and when
I started to have a
new life in Paris,
I thought that there's no need.
There is no need to do that.
We have our civilization,
or whatever,
which is very fantastic.
But who are we now?
And who I am now?
I need many things to
learn from this country.
So there's no need
to fight to show
that I am an
established character
and whatever, you know?
SPEAKER 4: Not as an Iranian.
As Shabnam, for
example, as a celebrity,
this feeling is much,
much worse, for example,
as nobody knows you.
Nobody knows your work.
So, as Shabnam, what did
you do to prove yourself
that you were a celebrity?
You were-- [INAUDIBLE].
SHABNAM TOLOUEI: Nothing.
SPEAKER 4: Nothing.
During-- I left Iran
in 2004, December 2004.
Till 2007, I was doing nothing.
I remember, I was going
to language school.
And this was just a
simple question, just
to make you talk in French.
So, who are you and
what do you want to be?
Because the others were young--
many young people.
And I was saying, I
was working in theater.
What was I doing?
No details.
So they could imagine that I
was working in administration
or whatever.
I was working in theater.
What are you going to be?
I don't know.
I'm just studying French.
You know?
I really didn't know.
And I was so shy.
I was too shy to
explain who I was.
I was really lost.
So I didn't even try
to talk about myself.
Then, miraculously?
[INAUDIBLE] appeared.
And she wanted me
to play in her film.
And then, I started
to talk about myself,
around me, to my friends.
And you know?
I started to work.
Then I started to work.
I went to Germany for a play.
I stayed there for two years.
So, I started to work.
And just by my works, I tried
to show the audience, not
the people--
I mean, not the power--
just the audience that I exist.
And please, please come.
I have something
to share with you.
This is what I did.
SPEAKER 1: And what has been
the greatest challenge you have
faced in your career to date?
SHABNAM TOLOUEI: Every time
that I want to go on stage--
for me, this is my great
challenge, you know?
I am like a child.
I start from the point of zero.
I am excited.
I'm nervous.
I think that I
can't do anything.
And this is a big challenge
for me every time.
So I can't mention
a particular event
that this was my
great challenge.
SPEAKER 1: So, stage fright?
Do you get--
SHABNAM TOLOUEI: Yes.
SPEAKER 1: I can--
SHABNAM TOLOUEI: And after
five minutes, I feel OK.
And then--
SPEAKER 1: Breathing.
SHABNAM TOLOUEI: I go forward.
SPEAKER 1: Question?
SPEAKER 5: Yes.
I have a two-part question.
As a multi-lingual
person, sometimes we
have different personalities
depending on the language
that we speak.
How did you consolidate
these distractions
or different forces that
internally you have?
Or you may not have?
SHABNAM TOLOUEI: I
don't know, really.
You know?
It's about 13 years that
I'm living in France.
Maybe I have, you know, I
have become another person
with a mixture of
gestures or characters.
I don't know.
Because when my friends come
from Iran and stay in my house,
they say, oh Shabnam,
you have changed a lot.
I don't understand
that, you know?
But I'm so much influenced by
the society that I'm living in.
And by the language and by
body language, you know?
So, that's interesting.
What you say,
that's interesting.
But I never, you know--
I was not aware about that.
SPEAKER 5: Thank you.
SPEAKER 6: But your
son was born in Paris.
SHABNAM TOLOUEI: Yes.
SPEAKER 6: And he's French.
So, how do you deal with that?
I mean, what's the feeling?
You had a life.
And how do you
explain it to him?
He's a kid.
But he also needs
to know, because he
sees your challenges.
SHABNAM TOLOUEI: Yes.
My son is eight years now.
He was 3 and 1/2,
and he was in school.
I went to take him from school.
And he started crying
when he saw me.
And he said, you know Paul--
his friend-- has broken my--
whatever.
And I said, oh, this
is the third time.
But why?
Why is he did this much?
You know, why?
And why did he do that?
I went to Paul.
And I said, Paul,
why did you do that?
And he said, no, no, no.
It was not me this time.
It was him.
And I went to my son, and
I said, did you lie to me?
And he was so happy because, you
know, he had found a solution.
So he started to lie.
So he said, yes, yes I lied.
And then I said, OK.
You have your snack.
And then we sit and we talk.
And then I told him my story.
I said, you know, I was
in Iran and I [INAUDIBLE]..
And I told the truth.
And I was fired.
And now I am here.
And he said, oh my god.
But you could have lied.
And I said, yes, but, I didn't.
So I just want you to tell
the truth all the time
and to take the responsibility
of the consequences.
And since then, it
was very interesting.
He said-- he used
a bad word for me.
I mean, he said,
._?} It
means that you're crazy.
Stupid.
But since then, he
tells the truth.
He tells everything.
And now, I have to tell
him that there is no need
to tell everything, you know?
There are some secrets.
Please keep at least my secrets.
But he tells the truth.
Even if something bad happens,
and he say, Mom, I did that.
But OK.
I accepted the consequences.
So, this is the only lesson
that I can bring from my past,
you know, for him.
Otherwise, I try to adapt
myself to his situation.
Because as you say, he's
a French, you know, child.
So I need to see
what is happening
for him in this society.
I need to go to his school.
I need to accompany him
in different events.
And you know, he
takes me with him.
SPEAKER 6: So it
was benediction.
SHABNAM TOLOUEI: Yes.
Yes, of course.
Yes.
To help me to--
yes, to live in the
present moment with him.
Thank you.
SPEAKER 1: Well thank
you so much, Shabnam.
I know some of these memories
are not easy to relive.
So, thank you.
Thank you for being here.
Thank you for--
SHABNAM TOLOUEI:
Thank you so much.
Thank you for your invitation.
Thank you for your patience.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]